[Music]
Suburgatory doing very well very popular
your character on that show is very
sexual is that fairness issues I see
that's fair that's fair to say she's
very comfortable with her sexuality
he is very yeah yeah you know she has my
character is Dallas and she has a big
crush on Jeremy Sisto yeah because he's
super cute and so the writers keep
writing these things for me to do you
know we have on the show on Suburgatory
George and Dallas get together and
Dallas wants it to be a night that he'll
always remember yes yes they have me
coming down from the ceiling in a
harness that was that something anybody
really does do they do that
well you know there's no harness that
could hold me honest and that's a union
thing so I mean we have a picture of
that scene where your character is first
of all I've never heard of that a woman
coming down on a harness yeah making a
like making an entrance and a landing
that it's for right I don't know why are
you asking me yeah I must know that's
what it's all about
you're a guy you know sure I'm a guy
I've got 900 harnesses back at home
like some electric hydraulic thing like
really and then lowering yeah yeah you
know that would break right you know
what I mean it'd be like part way down
and then it would stop and you'd have to
call people to come fix it yeah your
lady's up there and it's just that's
embarrassing yes I mean I think your
character is very sexually adventurous
yeah has this you play this character as
this informed your own life at all as it
made you want to be more adventurous
well it's made me realize that I think
I'm lazy I mean if this is what people
are doing if indeed people are doing
this doing this first of all no one here
has a harness and only do you have a
harness people will do anything you feel
like I need to like crank it up a bit so
does it make you feel like you play this
character no no let's have a lady but
like you you you need to expand your
horizons a little girl I do feel like
that yeah in real life I feel like I
need to expand my horizon think well a
lot of us feel that way you know I know
I owe ya you know you could use a little
would you kid yeah I'm the most
repressed freak in the world yeah this
is the most naked I get right here this
is it this is me you know you should
watch a Suburgatory and pick up some
tips from Dallas yeah oh I'll get a
harness I'll get the whole thing all
kinds of crazy choir yeah to watch you
do it wait what what are you talking
about I know but now I would never be
able to do anything in front of a gospel
choir I think you need to loosen up yes
that's been established 20 years on
television that's been the true line is
that I need to loosen up but that would
never happen